un cúmulo de miles de galaxias y una
mínima parte del cosmos a todo color la
nasa reveló la imagen infrarroja más
lejana y precisa del universo captada
hasta la fecha cobra el telescopio james
webb el mayor y más potente observatorio
astronómico lanzado al espacio con un
costo superior a los nueve mil millones
de dólares
si tú estuvieras un grano de arena en la
punta de tu dedo a la distancia de un
brazo sostenido esa es la parte del
universo que estás viendo sólo una
pequeña mota del universo
ubicado a unos 15 millones de kilómetros
de la tierra web es el sucesor del
telescopio hubble consta de un espejo
primario mucho más grande y sensible
capaz de ver muchos años más atrás en el
tiempo casi hasta los orígenes de
nuestro universo el james webb es la
siguiente etapa el hecho de cambiar luz
óptica o ultravioleta por infrarroja nos
permite ver más lejos nos permite el
objeto más ser más fríos planetas un
universo que está por descubrirse para
el universo muy distante de las galaxias
primeras que estaban naciendo se verá en
el infrarrojo y para las estrellas y
planetas que están naciendo o muriendo
se ven en el infrarrojo la toma se
presentó en una sesión informativa de la
casa blanca y este martes se publicarán
otras cuatro imágenes que incluyen la
vista de la nebulosa carina y la del
anillo sur cada una a miles de años luz
de la tierra
el presidente estadounidense recalcó
este hito histórico para su país y la
humanidad
estas imágenes van a recordar al mundo
que eeuu puede hacer grandes cosas más
web fue lanzado al espacio el día de
navidad de 2021 desde la guyana francesa
y se trata de uno de los mayores
proyectos científicos hasta el momento
su diseño y construcción se prolongó por
casi tres décadas en colaboración entre
la agencia espacial estadounidense y sus
homólogos europeos y canadienses